ce jouet cette arme factice restera ce
soir dans les placards pas possible de
se balader avec ce genre d'objet dans
les rues d'orléans
ainsi en a décidé la mairie une mesure
plutôt bien accueillie par ses clients
venus faire leurs derniers achats
halloween
parce que je pensais qu effectivement
des gens peuvent avoir peur et au vu de
l'actualité c'est très bien qu'ils aient
pas d'armes factices à ce jour un joueur
est un jouet je pense
après effectivement si les jeunes s'en
servent pour faire peur on peut croire
que ce soit que ce sont de vraies armes
et effectivement ça peut être très grave
en plus de l'interdiction du port
d'armes factices les regroupements de
personnes ne seront pas autorisés tout
cela pour éviter des débordements comme
ceux de 2015 la nuit d'halloween avait
mal tourné
des voitures avaient été prises pour
cible et saccagé je rappelle quand même
que à l'origine c'est les enfants qui
vont chercher des bonbons des sucreries
en faisant un peu du porte à porte
maintenant quand on est sur d'autres
débordements passe à autre chose et ça
c'est pas tolérable c'est toujours la
même histoire il faut savoir garder des
limites et et ne pas faire en sorte que
la fête des vies en drame
la mairie a prévenu des policiers seront
sur le terrain pour faire respecter
s'est arrêté vous l'avez compris
l'objectif est de profiter de la c'est
en toute sérénité
certains commerçants s'y sont déjà bien
préparé